it's so obvious this is the truth and
there's no arguing it that there are
trillions of dollars that are being
hoarded by the demon of lack and
separation and Silo rather than being
invested into free energy and basic
needs there's no arguing it you have all
of these archetypes of the solar Punk
decentralized basic needs future of
abundance for all and freedom for all of
humanity and then you have these
trillions of dollars that are being
hoarded by global Elites that are where
they could easily be put into free
energy systems and easily be put into
decentralizing basic needs and abundance
for all but they're not they're not and
this list goes on and on and on and on
with people that have billions and
billions and billions of dollars
with a B billions of dollars and it goes
on and on and on and on the selfishness
the greed the corruption the ego
the satanic programs that are running
that prevent the obliteration of of The
Silo of
Separation so there's just no hiding it
anymore and there's no repressing it
anymore it's going to be said exactly
how it is because this is exactly how it
is we have everything to build free
energy systems and basic needs
infrastructures and Free People and yet
we don't so let's be real about
it and call it out exactly how it is and
Shepherd the building of that new Earth
and generate these catalysts